IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME
WHICH I THINK IS GOING TO BE ONE
OF OUR NEW BIGGEST GAMES ON THE
SHOW.
"RYAN GOSLING OR RYAN SEACREST
FAN FICTION."
(cheers and applause)
I'M GOING TO READ YOU EXCERPTS
FROM FAN FICTION THAT I FOUND ON
THE INTERNET AND FOR 250 POINTS
I WANT YOU TO TELL ME WHICH OF
THE RYANS IT IS.
SO YOU'LL ANSWER GOSLING OR
SEACREST.
HERE WE GO, HERE'S THE FIRST
ONE.
RYAN SAID, STILL CRYING, "YEAH,
I KNOW THAT NOW.
WE SHOULD OF...
(laughter)
BUT I'M SORRY, TOO.
I FEEL SO BAD HOW THE WAY I
TREATED HIM.
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN TREAT AN
ANIMAL HOW I TREATED HIM."
YES, JULIE KLAUSNER.
>> SEACREST.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS SEACREST,
RYAN SEACREST.
>> WAS THIS THE CHAPTER ABOUT
WILLIAM HUNG?
(laughter)
>> Chris: IT SHOULD "OF" BEEN.
HERE'S THE NEXT ONE.
"SO I WAS JUST A ONE
NIGHTSTAND FOR YOU?"
YES, PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> A ONE NIGHTSTAND.
>> Chris: I WAS JUST A
NIGHTSTAND.
NEXT TO YOUR BED.
>> JUST ONE NIGHTSTAND.
>> Chris: I'M JUST ONE, THERE'S
ONLY ONE OF ME.
>> THIS HAS GOT TO BE A GOSLING.
>> THIS IS IN FACT A GOSLING,
YES, POINTS, POINTS.
(cheers and applause)
>> SO I WASN'T JUST A ONE
NIGHTSTAND FOR YOU.
>> Chris: SURE CAN'T WAIT TO GET
HOME TO MY LIVING NIGHTSTAND.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE.
"THEY LEFT A FOUR-YEAR-OLD
CHILD WITH YOU, RYAN.
SARAH STATED ALOUD."
WHICH IS HOW YOU STATE THINGS.
>> YEAH, IT'S HELPFUL.
>> Chris: "WHAT?
RYAN BURST OUT.
IT STATES HERE IN THE WILL THEY
LEFT THIS CHILD TO YOU.
SARAH STATED.
OH...MY...GOD."
PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> IT ENRAGES ME TO SAY THAT I
THINK THAT IS RYAN SEACREST.
>> THAT IS A SEACREST.
THAT IS A SEACREST.
HE GOTS THE DOLLARS.
>> THIS IS SO MUCH MORE ABOUT
THEIR FANS THAN IT IS ABOUT
THEM.
>> Chris: HERE'S THE NEXT ONE.
"GREAT, SHE SMILED AND TURNED
BACK FOR THE RESTROOMS."
THAT'S WHO THE (BLEEP) KNOWS.
YEAH, PAUL.
>> I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT I
THINK THAT THAT IS RYAN GOSLING
FAN FICTION.
>> THAT IS A GOSLING!
THAT IS A GOSLING!
(cheers and applause)
THERE HE IS WATCHING HER WALK TO
THE RESTROOM OFF IN THE
DISTANCE.
>> IN HIS PAJAMAS OUTSIDE?
>> YEAH, HE GOT OUT OF BED TO
MAKE SURE SHE GOT TO THE
BATHROOM SAFELY.
NEXT ONE.
"YOU'RE SHAUNI RIGHT?
THE ONE WHO I ONCE SENT A REPLY
TO ON MYSPACE?"
VERY TIMELY, VERY TIMELY.
"THE MAJORLY DEVOTED FAN"?
JULIE.
>> THAT'S RYAN SEACREST.
>> THAT WOULD BE ACTUALLY
RYAN...
GOSLING.
NO, THAT'S RYAN GOSLING.
>> NO!
>> GOSLING IS STILL A MYSPACE
GUY, I DON'T KNOW.
HE'S RIGHT THERE, HE'S THINKING
ABOUT MYSPACE, WHAT WENT WRONG.
WHO'S IN MY TOP EIGHT?
LIKE YOU CAN SEE ALL THE WHEELS
TURNING.
>> APPARENTLY THE BEST AUTHOR OF
ALL-TIME SHAUNI IS IN HIS TOP
EIGHT.
>> Chris: BARON, DO YOU HAVE A
THOUGHT ON THIS?
>> NO.
(laughter)
(cheers and applause)
>> Chris: NICE!
POINTS!